what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are really continuing not
really getting into but we're continuing
scott Snyder's Justice League now this
picks up really with the creation and
continuation of like the Hall of Justice
but it also deals with a group called a
corona Wars which is kind of interesting
concept what Scott Snyder does released
like what it seems like he does is he's
taking like these old-school JLA stories
like Justice League of America really
just Justice League nowadays but he's
taking like these Justice League story
is from like not early to mid 60s and
kind of like blending the men where the
kind of stories that we expect in this
day and age but initially this deals
with Superman and facing off against
these Corona boy things which are
basically like these small little drones
that basically consume like like solar
energy now the whole time this is
happening you've got Superman talking
directly to Batman is it's one of these
things were like Scott Snyder kind of
confirms these small little things for
example Superman holds his breath in
space he doesn't actually breathe in
space little things like that small
little things that that really
contribute to a greater whole but the
entire time this is happening Batman's
warning Superman that these are just
small drones that feed off of solar
energy and the Superman while he is in
the presence of the Yellow Sun there's
got to be some kind of like a mega
around around there somewhere some being
that's powerful enough to basically kill
Superman now what did I bear in mind and
one thing to notice here is that
Superman doesn't really seem to care
he's not really worried about them he's
just kind of like yeah you know they're
a thing that's there and it's
interesting but it's a little
disconcerting at the same time because
normally when it comes to really
anything powerful enough to potentially
kill Superman that Superman himself
usually shifts away from being just kind
of like not really concerned and becomes
concerned not so much because of the
fact that may or may not kill him that's
using out what he's worried about is
because if it's something out there
powerful enough to physically challenged
him then what does it say about the
other superheroes on earth there's a few
characters here and there but with
regards to the Earth's populace it'd be
a legitimate threat and so what this
does is it switches back to earth and it
focuses with the opening of the Hall of
Justice now really if anything this is
like a scott snyder love letter to DC
fans and i feel like it's something that
was very much needed I feel like it's
something that was there was very much
needed in this sensitive Scott's Scott's
that are kind of saying hey DC fans we
love you we haven't forgotten about you
we know the lot of you guys really love
the Hall of Justice a lot of you guys
really enjoyed having that whole thing
around where you had sort of like a
earth-based place where the Justice
League would operate out up it's a
throwback to the things that so many DC
fans missed after the new 52 happened
bring you back a lot of these old
familiar things now one of the reasons
why the halt of just
is so cool here is because while it is
an operating base for the Justice League
it's also a tourist attraction basically
people can go there and make in like
tour the whole place and what makes that
so interesting is the the Justice League
will operate out of it while people are
touring through it so it's like you go
in there and you see everything that
goes on like here's where we conduct our
meetings all these them and things oh
hey there's Green Lantern you know like
it sees these cool little moments these
cool little things and this is really a
hallmark of DC this is one of the ways
that DC kind of stood out for Marvel
Comics in a lot of different ways its
fans could live vicariously through the
normal Earthlings that are going through
the the Hall of Justice and imagine what
it would be like to actually tour
through that itself and it seems like it
wouldn't be that big of a thing but if
you're somebody who is born and raised
in DC Comics it's a core part of your of
your of your reading base this was a way
that DC would connect with fans now with
regards to this this little moment here
at the Justice League kind of hanging
out and talking with each other we
switch over to flash and we switch over
to John Stewart the Green Lantern and
this is a very important conversation
because as we've known as we've seen
from Scott Snyder's totality arc ah that
is to say like his first arc in in
Justice League that things are changing
and they have been for some time
following the events of Dark Knights
metal there was a crack in the source
wall the multiverse is bleeding and it's
basically dying that with the
establishment of the ultraviolet course
where the establishment of like the
still force and the sage force and
things like that the universe is
changing rapidly in ways that like a lot
of the superheroes cannot really keep up
with and so that's when Barry talks to
talks to Jon Stewart incident of what
you have to do is you can't focus on the
things that are shifting so rapidly you
have to focus on what you know and use
that as your anchor point now this is
Barry coming to this whole experience
from a variety of different places right
I mean it's him coming from this with
like hey I was trapped in the Speed
Force my escape from the Speed Force was
orchestrated by having an anchor in the
main DC universe in the form of iris
west of my wife that I could basically
reach out to and pull myself out of the
Speed Force but it's also a little
deeper than that it's also the idea that
like things do change like life changes
all the time and it can be very very
very scary especially when it's when
it's when it's a huge change in a very
short amount of time losing a job having
a breakup moving from one location to
the next these often times set in
psychological responses depression
anxiety
things like that so like we all
experience these things and that's why
Scott Snyder writing is so relatable
because while it does deal with
superhero antics and you know the court
of owls and Batman in the
Joker returning with his face cut off at
the end of the day it is like a shift in
the status quo and it's an extreme shift
in the status quo though we can relate
to because we experience those extreme
shifts in status quo so again from there
we end up going into Diana Prince
talking with Aquaman because of course
Green Lantern and flash are basically
call off by Batman saying hey look
things are getting ready to pop off at
the moon Superman's gonna need some help
he says he doesn't need it but like he
does so like we all need to go help him
out but shifting over to Aquaman and
Wonder Woman what we end up finding out
is that what's been happening here at
the Hall of Justice is that each members
of the Justice League have created their
domain kind of a safe place for
themselves a place is basically like all
their own as over Aquaman it's kind of a
mock-up of of Atlantis you know with
like his father's boat and something
akin to amnesty Bay with Superman it's
basically like his work desk at the
Daily Planet with Batman it's the
coolest okay let me tell you something
like I feel like Batman I feel like
Bruce Wayne if he'd formed a club when
he was a kid he would just be like uh no
Girls Aloud Club you know like it's
literally a bad symbol that says keep
out how cool is that
like I feel see stuff like that makes me
want to hang out with Batman like like
wouldn't it be cool to join it like a
Batman Club we're like okay guys we are
the first official meeting of the bat
Club no girls allowed and it's like yeah
I was like like I feel like oh you know
what it would be like it would be like
the tree house from like Sandlot that's
what it would be like but you guys
understand what I'm saying here these
are small little sections of the Hall of
Justice
that are modeled after each individual
person now the most interesting thing
here is Martian Manhunter
that's what's so intriguing here Martian
Manhunter has historically been a
character who's a fish out of water so
to speak right like originally when he
first showed up in DC Comics he was just
a Martian on earth and his people
existed on Mars
it wasn't until later on going into like
the later years leading up to Christ on
Infinite Earths and especially
post-crisis that he was like
quote-unquote the last of his kind and
always wanted to always want to return
home he was very Superman esque in that
regard now that was just a build-up
because of the fact that when he was
first introduced he was a stand-in for
Superman on the Justice League so he
didn't have to worry about overexposing
Superman and driving away fans who
otherwise would have had a reason to
read his character and so as Martian
Manhunter was on the Justice League he
basically became closer to Superman in
terms of how he was depicted hence the
reason why he ended up being the last of
his kind but but for that reason Martian
Manhunter doesn't really have a home
he's got little bits of history and
little things like that but the his his
whole area is just kind of like a giant
void his wish
just like this giant vault more or less
and what he does is he caters the the
appearance of the vault to whoever shows
up there when you've got hot bro you've
got like this giant trophy room yeah
you've got all these these these cool
little things you know like the Justice
League Darts headquarters or like these
you know this this giant magically
infused place I mean it's just it's it's
cool little things here and the idea is
that Wonder Woman hasn't quite found
where she belongs
that seems to be the indication and it
works because for the most part Diana
Prince has always kind of been homeless
so to speak which is to say she was
booted out of him or she left a mascara
and she could never go back during Greg
Rutgers run it was established that all
the times she thought she was returning
to that mascara she never was does she's
never actually been back to thermosphere
which was kind of like kind of a cool
thing but because of the fact that she's
just kind of there and in sort of
occupies a space that is fee it seems
like from from her perspective she
hasn't really built her hall because she
feels lost but the reality is that she's
been building at this whole time these
pillars she's been establishing they're
based on faith her faith in in in being
a superhero her faith in her team and so
it's basically like hey look I don't
really need to have a place to operate
his home we know at the end of the day
she's sharing she's sharing a bed with
somebody but like like you know it's
like I don't really need to have a bed
person or have like a home per se but
like we know that like I have faith in
everything and the Justice League is my
home more or less you know something
akin to that but it's kind of a cool
thing because with this mega showing up
and with Superman still on the moon
Batman of course with symbols everybody
and says hey you guys all have to
respond and this is when we get this
explanation for why Superman's not too
worried about it because soon as
responses know Batman there is nothing
to worry about
because you sent this corona for here
you sent this here because like hey we
have to team up we have to change as a
team if superman recognizes that because
when it comes to the Justice League in
recent years they've kind of been
fractured and that's one of the things
that people have noticed is one of the
things that I have noticed you look at
new 52 Justice League you look at the
early days of rebirth Justice League and
there's somewhat of a fractured team I
made sure they work together but they're
together by circumstance they're not
really together because they see
themselves as an actual team and this is
one of those circumstances where the
more things change the more they stay
the same
Justice League made their debut and
brave in the Boldin they got their own
solo series back in the 50s and 60s and
that runs up for 25 years and a crisis
on Infinite Earths DC get disband the
team they lost Justice League
International then we get like extreme
justice and we get just Justice League
Europe and so on and so forth that goes
into 1998 when Grant Morrison brings
them back with Jael a volume 2 and so
with that whole thing that was like the
return of the Justice League it was the
world needs the Justice League and
so they started operating as more of a
cohesive team now at the end of the day
they still had problems because you had
like Tower of Babel where Batman which
is being a dick but the idea here is
that each member of the Justice League
represents something significant Martian
Manhunter is the unifying factor the one
that holds the team together
if only due to his telepathy you've got
here a Saunders you got Hawkgirl and
sometimes Hawkman who exists as this
kind of hey we lived a thousand lives a
thousand times we've got all kinds of
history and experience we bring to the
table Batman's the brains of the
operation
Superman a Wonder Woman or the Brawn of
the operation everybody has their own
sort of of role they play but for
Superman he's also kind of like the hope
of the operation it's never too late to
win there's always hope to come out at
the end of the day and that's kind of
what Superman recognizes the role that
he plays the role that Batman plays Hey
look we're fine as a team what we needed
was something cohesive but we need it
was a home to call our own and we have
that in the form of the Hall of Justice
that's what we have we have to be the
Justice League team that the world looks
up to that the world aspires to though
the world sees is kind of like saviors
for them we have to embody hope and so
long as we function as a team so long as
we work as a cohesive unit we will have
that and that's what's so cool is
because Superman as he exists now in DC
we birth is a Superman from before the
new 52 the version that everybody missed
and he kind of comes along and says guys
like we're good
we just haven't recognized what each of
us brings to the table but now we do now
we realize we are a cohesive team we've
had a lot of crabby circumstances
recently we've had Dark Knight's metal
we've had Justice Lost we've had Justice
League no justice we've had a lot of
issues going on but we're still together
and that has to speak for something as
long as we take comfort in that then we
can go forward as an actual team
beautifully written story absolutely
amazing story but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rod for if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]